THAT IS TONIGHT'S FRIDAY
NIGHT BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
♪
>> ALL RIGHT.
THERE IS A TON OF
INFORMATION TO COVER
TONIGHT.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO POINT
BY POINT THROUGH THE MEMO.
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU
IMPORTANT BACKGROUND
INFORMATION SO WE CAN FULLY
EXPLAIN JUST HOW MASSIVE
THIS SCANDAL IS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
PIECE EVERY SINGLE NIGHT NOW
FOR MONTHS.
WE HAVE BEEN WAY AHEAD OF
THE CURVE.
BUT, THERE IS NEW VITAL
INFORMATION THAT IS EVEN
MORE DAMNING, MORE DAMAGING
THAN ANYTHING WE HAVE TOLD
EXPLAINING, THIS IS
WATERGATE TIMES A THOUSAND.
YOU'RE ABOUT TO FIND OUT WHY
AND HERE ARE THE DEFININGS
FROM THE MEMO THAT WE'RE
GOING TO COVER IN DETAIL.
HERE IS WHAT YOU NEED TO
KNOW.
THE FBI DEEP STATE
OFFICIALS, THEY USED A
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
THAT WAS FILLED WITH RUSSIAN
LIES, RUSSIAN POP GRANDA.
TOTALLY UNVERIFIED, TO LIE
TO A FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
SURVEILLANCE COURT TO OBTAIN
A WARRANT SO THEY COULD SPY
ON TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISOR
CARTER PAGE.
THE FBI OR AT LEAST THE YOU
WERE ECHELON, NOT THE RANK
AND FILE, REPEATEDLY NEVER
TOLD THE FISA JUDGES THAT
QUAY WAS FINANCED BY HILLARY
CLINTON AND THE DNC.
IN OTHER WORDS THEY OMITTED
CRUCIAL INFORMATION FROM THE
FISA COURT JUDGE SO THEY
COULD CONTINUE THIS PROCESS.
JAMES COMEY, ANDREW MCCABE,
SALLY YATES, DANA, ROD
ROSENSTEIN, THEY ARE ALL
COMPLICIT IN THIS BECAUSE
THEY, AT DIFFERENT POINTS,
THEY ALL APPROVED
SURVEILLANCE ON PAGE.
NOW, THIS PART IS SHOCKING.
THE FBI THEN USED A YAHOO
NEWS REPORT THAT WAS WRITTEN
BY MICHAEL FROM
SEPTEMBER 23RD, 2016 ABOUT A
CARTER PAGE TRIP TO RUSSIA
AS EVIDENCE TO CORROBORATE
INFORMATION IN THE PHONY
RUSSIAN PAID FOR DOSSIER.
HERE'S THE THING.
AND THIS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
THE SOURCE FOR THE
INFORMATION AND THE YAHOO
NEWS REPORT WAS NONE OTHER
THAN CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THE
SO, THE FBI USED STEELE'S
LEAK TO YAHOO TO CORROBORATE
THE DOSSIER CREATED BY THE
SAME PERSON STEELE.
THIS IS WHAT WE CALL
CIRCULAR REPORTING BECAUSE
IN FACT, IT WAS THE SAME
SOURCE.
AND THEY WERE PRESENTING
THAT TO THE JUDGE.
NOW, THE MEMO WAS ALSO
EXPOSING HOW CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, THE FORMER BRITISH
RUSSIAN SOURCES, HAD
PREVIOUSLY WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE FBI WAS SUSPENDED
AND THEN TERMINATED AS AN
FBI SOURCE FOR LEAKING TO
THE PRESS ABOUT HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
BUREAU.
WE ALSO KNOW INDEPENDENTLY
FROM THE MEMO THAT IN
SEPTEMBER 2016 STEELE AND
FUSION GPS BRIEFED IN
PERSON, IN PERSON SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS FROM THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" AND "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND YAHOO
CLINTON PHONY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
AND GLENN SIMPSON TESTIFIED
THAT BOTH THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC WERE
WELL AWARE ABOUT THIS PRESS
SO, IN OTHER WORDS, HILLARY
CLINTON WANTED THE MEDIA TO
RUN WITH THIS TOTAL, FALSE,
FABRICATED DOSSIER HOPING TO
LIE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND CONVINCE YOU THAT'S A
REASON TO VOTE FOR HER AND
NOT DONALD TRUMP.
NOW, LET'S GET BACK TO THE
JUSTICE OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR.
REMEMBER, OHR WAS THE GUY
WHO HAD AN OFFICE FOUR DAYS
DOWN FROM ROD ROSENSTEIN AND
REMOVED FROM HIS POSITION
FOR NOT DISCLOSING THAT HE
MET WITH FUSION GPS BOTH
BEFORE AND AFTER THE
ELECTIONS.
NOW, BRUCE'S WIFE, HER NAME
IS NELLIE OHR, SHE WORKED
FOR FUSION GPS.
SHE WAS HIRED TO FIGURE UP
DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP FOR THE
DOSSIER.
AND ALSO REVEALED DURING
SEPTEMBER 2016 STEELE SAID
TRUMP NOT GET ELECTED AND
WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT HIM NOT
BEING PRESIDENT.
I THOUGHT WE DIDN'T LIKE
OUTSIDERS INFLUENCING OUR
ELECTIONS.
NOW, ACCORDING TO THE MEMO,
NONE OF THIS WAS DISCLOSED
I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR FROM
THE MEMO THAT DURING THE
INITIAL APPLICATION WARRANT
AHEAD OF THE FBI COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE DIVISION SAYS
THE CORROBORATION OF THE
STEELE DOSSIER WAS, QUOTE,
IN ITS INFANCY.
IN OTHER WORDS, THAT MEANS
THE FBI NEVER CORROBORATED
TO A FISA COURT TO GET A
WARRANT TO SPY ON AN
OPPOSITION CANDIDATE WHEN
ONE CANDIDATE PAID FOR THOSE
LIES.
THE MEMO EXPLAINED HOW
ANDREW MCCABE TESTIFIED
BEFORE THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
THAT THE FISA WARRANT TO SPY
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN APPROVED
WITHOUT THE DOSSIER.
SO WHEN YOU PUT ALL THIS
INFORMATION TOGETHER, HERE
PERSONALLY SEE RECEIVED
COURT USING UNVERIFIED,
COMPLETELY PHONY OPPOSITION
SPY ON AN OPPOSITION
CAMPAIGN DURING A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
ALL TO HELP ONE CANDIDATE
OUT.
ALL TO MISLEAD THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
NOW, THAT TYPE OF ABUSE OF
POWER, THAT TYPE OF
CORRUPTION, THAT SHREDDING
OF THE CONSTITUTION IT IS
UNPRECEDENTED IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
NOW, THE FISA LAWS, WHICH
ARE ALL ABOUT YOUR
GOVERNMENT SPYING ON
SURVEIL ON AN OPPOSITION
CAMPAIGN TO UNDERMINE LATER
A DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE NEVER, EVER IN
HISTORY SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
BY RANK AND FILE MEMBERS OF
THE FBI INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, NO.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, PETER
STRZOK, LISA PAGE, LIKELY
LORETTA LYNCH.
AND WE CAN ALSO TELL YOU
TONIGHT MANY OTHERS.
WE WILL BE LEARNING ABOUT IN
COMING DAYS.
DID NOT KNOW THAT THE FBI
WAS LYING TO A FISA COURT IN
ORDER TO SPY ON AN
OPPOSITION CAMPAIGN DURING
AN ELECTION YEAR.
THEY HAVE AIDED AND ABETTED
WHAT IS A MASSIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL VIOLATION.
ALL NEED TO BE INVESTIGATED
AND, IN MANY CASES,
PROSECUTED TO THE FULLEST
BEEN COMMITTED.
REMEMBER, COMEY TESTIFIED
UNDER OATH THE DOSSIER WAS
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
REMEMBER HE TOLD THAT TO
DONALD TRUMP WHEN HE WAS THE
THE HELL DID HE USE IT TWO
MONTHS EARLIER TO GET A FISA
WARRANT?
NOW, OF COURSE, COMEY IS
RUNNING SCARED.
HE IS OUT OF HIS MIND RIGHT
DISHONEST, MISLEADING MEMO,
WRECK THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, DESTROY TRUST
WITH THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, DAMAGE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FISA
COURT AND EXCLUSIVABLY
EXPOSED CLASSIFIED
INVESTIGATION OF AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
FOR WHAT?
DOJ AND FBI MUST KEEP DOING
THEIR JOBS.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
THE ONLY THING THAT WAS
DISHONEST AND MISLEADING IN
THIS WAS JIM COMEY.
AS I SAID LAST NIGHT, JIM,
YOU MIGHT WANT TO KEEP YOUR
MOUTH SHUT BECAUSE ANYTHING
LAW.
AND DO YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
AN ATTORNEY.
AND SPEAKING OF ROSENSTEIN,
NOW, REMEMBER, THIS IS A GUY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL RECUSED
HIMSELF.
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE HIS
ACTIONS NOW PROVE HE ISN'T
CAPABLE OF HONESTLY SERVING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND HERE'S ANOTHER MASSIVE
REVELATION THAT I WANT YOU
WHAT WE NOW HAVE GONE
THROUGH, THIS MESS FOR A
YEAR, NO EVIDENCE, TRUMP,
RUSSIA COLLUSION, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, IT'S BEEN
BUILT ON LIES AND BUILT ON A
PHONY FAKE NEWS DOSSIER THAT
WAS FUNDED BY HILLARY
CLINTON.
NOW, THAT THE FBI THEN USED
THAT TO TARGET THEN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN THEN AN
INCOMING PRESIDENT.
NOW, IF THIS NEVER HAPPENED,
IT WOULD BE NO ROBERT
MUELLER.
AND THESE REVELATIONS ARE SO
PROFOUND, THIS CORRUPTION SO
DEEP, IT IS SO OBVIOUS THAT
THAT'S NOT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT MUELLER'S MASSIVE
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
HIMSELF AND HOW HIS TEAM IS
FILLED WITH BIG DEMOCRATIC
DONORS AND PEOPLE LIKE
SENDS PEOPLE TO JAIL.
OVERTURNED FIFTH CIRCUIT OF
APPEALS.
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION IS
AND HAS BEEN A WITCH-HUNT
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
IT'S BUILT ON HOUSE OF
CARDS, AND TONIGHT IT IS
CRASHING DOWN.
IF WE BELIEVE IN CIVIL
LIBERTIES, IF WE BELIEVE IN
THOSE PROTECTIONS, THEN THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUST BE
DISBANDED IMMEDIATELY.
BY THE WAY, NOBODY ELSE WILL
SAY.
MICHAEL FLYNN NEED TO BE
DROPPED.
IS REACTING TO ALL OF THIS
BREAKING NEWS.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
THE MEMO.
WANT TO KNOW THE TRUTH.
I THINK IT'S A DISGRACE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I THINK IT'S A DISGRACE.
THE MEMO WAS SENT TO
CONGRESS WHO HAS
DECLASSIFIED.
CONGRESS WILL DO WHATEVER
THEY ARE GOING TO DO.
BUT I THINK IT'S A DISGRACE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
COUNTRY.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
AND YOU SEE THAT AND SO MANY
OTHER THINGS WHAT'S GOING
ON, A LOT OF PEOPLE SHOULD
BE ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES AND
CONGRESS AND THEY WILL DO
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO,
IT WAS DECLASSIFIED.
AND LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ASHAMED.
>> Sean: MORE THAN ASHAMED.
A LOT OF PEOPLE BROKE THE
LAW.
CORRUPTION.
IT SHOULD SHATTER THE
CONSCIENCE OF LAW ABIDING
MINER CITIZENS.
FOX NEWS IS REPORTING
TONIGHT THE MEMO IS BEING
SENT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND INSPECTOR
GENERAL WHICH COULD LEAD TO
CRIMINAL CHARGES.
WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING THAT
THIS MEMO, BELIEVE IT OR
THIS SCANDAL IS ONLY IN
PHASE ONE.
THAT MORE MEMOS ARE COMING.
THIS MEMO HAS BEEN RELEASED.
LOOK, WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU ABOUT THIS FOR A VERY
LONG TIME, IT WAS MARCH OF
LAST YEAR WHEN WE FIRST
REPORTED THAT THERE WAS A
IS NOW BEING SHOWN TO BE
TRUE AND EXPOSED.
IN THE MEANTIME ALL THIS
WHILE THE LIBERAL MAINSTREAM
MEDIA THEY HAVE WASTED AN
ENTIRE YEAR HOLDING THIS
COUNTRY HOSTAGE ON A FALSE
NARRATIVE ON A CONSPIRACY
THEORY THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
COLLUDED WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THEY HAVE AND HAVE HAD NO
EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T EXIST U THE MEDIA
HAS BEEN CORRUPT AND LYING
TO YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THEY
ARE NOTHING BUT
PROPAGANDIST, AN EXTENSION
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
TIN FOIL HAT CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS THAT ARE SO
PATHOLOGICALLY LOCKED IN
THEIR HATE OF PRESIDENT
ALL THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
BUT YOU HAVE OVERPAID
JOURNALISTS JUST TOO LAZY TO
RIGIDLY IDEOLOGICAL TO DO
THEIR JOBS.
THEY HAVE BEEN SITTING ON
THE SIDELINES WHILE THE
BIGGEST SCANDAL IN THEIR
LIFE TIMES HAS BEEN
UNFOLDING RIGHT BEFORE THEIR
VERY FACES.
NOW, WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
TRUMP CAMPAIGN SINCE
MARCH 6TH OF LAST YEAR.
AND THE MEDIA HAS IGNORED IT
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
HERE IS WHAT I SAID THAT DAY
BACK ON MY RADIO SHOW IN
MARCH OF LAST YEAR.
>> THIS IS THE SWAMP, OBAMA
HOLDOVERS, LIFELONG
BUREAUCRATS.
THAT ARE SABOTAGING.
THIS IS THE SHADOW
GOVERNMENT I HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS WHAT DEEP STATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
A CARDINAL RULE OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION IS NO WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIAL EVER
INTERFERED WITH AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION
LED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
THAT'S NOT A DENIAL THAT IT
HAPPENED.
MEANING THE FISA COURT
REQUESTS.
AND IT SAYS THAT AS A MATTER
OF PRACTICE NEITHER THE
PRESIDENT NOR ANY WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIAL EVER ORDERED
SURVEILLANCE ON ANY U.S.
CITIZEN, ANY SUGGESTION --
THEY DIDN'T ORDER IT.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN OBAMA
DIDN'T KNOW THAT IT
HAPPENED.
WE HAVE TAKEN LOOT OF HEAT
FOR TELLING THE TRUTH.
THE EVIDENCE, THE FACTS, THE
TRUTH, THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD
PURSUE.
IT'S ALL THERE.
IT'S BEEN THERE.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
ANY OF THIS.
THEY WANT PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
FAIL.
OTHERWISE, THEY WOULD BE
BY THE WAY THEY ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN DO TO
TRY TO DISCREDIT IT AND IT'S
NOT GOING TO WORK.
NOW, HERE'S THE THING.
FACTS IS FACTS.
TRUTH IS TRUTH.
THE MEDIA CANNOT TWIST AND
DISTORT TRUTH AND YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND THOSE
OF YOU THAT HAVE SUPPORTED
THIS SHOW, WE THANK YOU
AND CONGRESSWOMEN.
YOU ASKED THEM TO RELEASE